new tractor owners listen up i made a
recent video about all the hidden costs
for tractor owners and it's true there
are a lot of hidden costs however
for the very basics just the bare
essentials that you need
that list is pretty short you don't have
to spend thousands of extra dollars
just to get started so when someone
starts chatting me up about what they
need for their new tractor what they
gotta get along with it to be kind of
set up right
well most of those answers are gonna be
custom tailored to fit their application
however there are a handful of things
required for every tractor owner
regardless of your task let's play a fun
game really quick in this one too
something is going to change in the
background of this video between the
beginning
and the end of it if you figure out what
it is leave a comment down below
fair warning this is just my opinion all
you seasoned vets out there
if you have something else you think
every tractor owner should have
let us know what that is by leaving a
comment down below you know what it
would really help me out if you would
give me a thumbs up and if you want to
see more helpful tractor videos hit that
subscribe button right down below
if you're in the market for some cool
tractors or tractor attachments
read through that description right
underneath the video or head on over to
goodworkstractors.com
so it's no secret i sell used equipment
so i am pretty particular about what i
bring in
not only in the condition of the
equipment but what features are found on
the tractors that i have for sale
for that reason it's going to be very
rare to see something out here that
doesn't have a quick attached bucket a
quick attached loader
you know a quick attach mower a quick
attach backhoe
a three-point quick attach the common
theme there is quick attach i want that
versatility for my customers
i think that paying a little bit more to
have equipment that has that kind of a
feature on there to allow you to make
um or to hook up different attachments
to the loader or take the loader off
quickly if you just want to mow
or take the backhoe off or hook up to
different three-point attachments a lot
easier
those kinds of features are worth their
weight in gold
so quick attach is really pretty
self-explanatory right but
the main benefits are going to be
efficiency and versatility so efficiency
because it's going to be very fast of
course to change
attachments out like take your bucket
off put pallet forks on or a snow pusher
or if you want to take your whole loader
off or your mower deck your backhoe
versatility again because you can take
your bucket off then you can put those
forks on you can put the snow pusher on
a grapple
instead of being just stuck with your
bucket and no quick way to go back and
forth between forks and a pusher or
anything else
and of course it's going to allow you to
do things the right way
if you're mowing your lawn you really
shouldn't have your load around and your
bucket on so if you can quickly take
this off
it's going to keep a lot of stress and
strain off of the front axle the tractor
it's going to allow you to maneuver in
tighter corners and the same thing if
you're trying to use your front end
loader or your three point
you want to be able to take your mower
deck off because this is an easy thing
to damage if you're driving along say
you're tilling
and or you're in your woods just driving
around and you hit a stump
and it whacks the mower deck and knocks
it out of alignment you could have some
costly repairs that way as well or
shorten
uh the lifespan of the axle for example
in other scenarios
so the easier it is to take on and off
the better off you are
this next essential for tractor owners
is free for everybody but it's something
that we all need and rely on we're using
it right now
and that's going to be support and it's
a great thing at this day and age as you
have so many versions and forms and ways
to get knowledge about your tractor
and that learning curve is really going
to get shortened the more that you kind
of
dive into it and understand what's going
on with your tractor how to use it
watching it in action you can do that in
a lot of different ways
youtube of course is a really good
platform
not my channel there's a lot of great
channels out there that show tractors in
action
all sorts of different setups different
configurations you can see what works
and what doesn't work
the right size equipment to fit your
machine same thing with facebook groups
there's a lot of cool mods that go on
there with
guys that are doing different custom
things to their tractors if you want to
see how to get different lighting on
there or just
different ways to kind of outfit it and
customize your tractor to fit your needs
along the lines of youtube and the
facebook groups
forums are going to be a fantastic place
for all sorts of tractor owners those
with a lot of experience those just
starting out and everywhere in between
to just get together ask and answer
those questions and it's not only going
to take care of
the situation at hand for that that
customer that user right at that point
but that information is there for
everybody else in the future to read and
digest and understand and hopefully
shorten their learning curve as well in
fact i think tractor forms are so
beneficial that on my new
website that's coming out soon you'll
want to stick around for that
goodworxtractors.com
i paid thousands of dollars extra to
have a forum
application built into that website that
way
i can direct folks right there we can
have a great community just to get those
questions
answered right there on the spot another
couple great ways to get support are
going to be
through your dealers so that's why i say
one of the big decisions in figuring out
the right tractor for you
john deere kubota coyote whoever is
checking out your local dealer do you
have good support there you know there's
good dealers and bad dealers most of
them are good out there right
but go ahead talk to those guys even if
you don't buy a tractor from them
a good dealer is still going to take
care of you if you need to get your
tractor service there or buy some parts
or accessories from them
that can make a difference between
getting a john deere a kubota or any
other brand
of course you can always reference your
user manual if you don't have a hard
copy
at least with john deere if you just
google john deere 10 25
hour manual or john deere 300 cx manual
you're gonna find
this same thing just in the online
version okay so it's the exact same
thing easy to reference but
even after all these years i've made
videos on the hidden things that i find
in these manuals that
maybe you just gloss over the first 10
times you read through it
but you kind of pick up on it eventually
so there's a lot of good stuff in here
i'd encourage you to read it
if you don't have a hard copy just get
it online something else that's not
going to cost you
a whole lot but could come in really
handy especially if you're in the middle
of a project
and all of a sudden need it something
like fasteners
linchpins cotter pins and i'll tell you
if you use a tiller if you use a brush
hog
snowblower anything along those lines
shear bolts are your best friend that's
not one of those things you want to
search around for
when you're out in the field and all of
a sudden one of these shears off
have some replacements on hand they're
super cheap just keep them with you you
may never need them if you get lucky but
if you do
you're going to be thankful you have
them with you even items like pins
for your three point attachments to your
quick hitch you know in fact last fall i
was doing some tilling and i
forgot i had adjusted my hook up and
down forgot to tighten down
one of my bolts and it actually came off
in the field so if you can
keep extra hardware around with you i
didn't
but if you do it'll save you a lot of
time so learn from my mistakes
and shorten your learning curve you know
when out here at least straps and chains
really come in handy with trying to move
things around but if you're out in the
woods as well
say you have a log somewhere that you
just can't push you got to kind of pull
it out of the way
great way to just strap to it and yank
it out of the way this way
so keeping something handy like this
will really help you out when you're in
a pinch
simple maintenance items will go a long
way to making your tractor last longer
and making a lot easier for you to use
if you can keep things on hand like a
rust release spray
some grease options as well they're
going to help you with attaching and
detaching to your different attachments
that you have
they're also going to make it so that
your loader your mower deck your backhoe
other things with grease zerks on there
your drive shafts are going to last a
lot longer it's very easy to do very
simple to do
you should have these kinds of products
on hand these are nothing you need to
take to a dealer to have done
even a couple simple tools like a hammer
and a set of channel locks will help you
when you're out in the field if you've
got to get
an attachment off or maybe an attachment
on it's just being stubborn
these hunks of steel will help you move
those other hunks of steel
now i don't care if you have a loader on
your tractor if you don't have a loader
if you have something on the back or not
everybody needs
ballast weight and stability okay
because you are not just using the
tractor you're going to have something
connected to it so whether it's a mower
and maybe you're just mowing around on a
side hill and you have to have some
weight to help keep you planted to the
ground
if you're using a front end loader
you've got to have some weight on the
back
different scenarios call for different
types of ballast weight and stability
so everybody's going to have a little
bit of a different requirement of that
kind of ballast weight or
spacers or dual wheels but i'll tell you
we all need stability on our tractors to
get our projects done safely
so talking about reading your owner's
manual this is where that's going to
come in handy because
if you're going to use your front end
loader it's going to tell you how much
weight you need to have on the back side
to offset that
you can accomplish that in a variety of
ways with suitcase weights with a
ballast box
with wheel weights with liquid ballast
inside your tires a lot of ways to go
about it
the point being you got to get it done
weight on the front of your tractor can
be useful in a couple different
scenarios sometimes
if you don't have your loader on and you
have maybe a heavy tiller or some other
piece of equipment on the back end
you want to have some more weight up
here to help keep you planted to the
ground
your loader is a good form of ballast
weight but it's not ideal for every
situation
and sometimes even this additional
weight up front will help keep your
front end planted to the ground when
you're using something on the front so
a snow pusher or a snow plow for example
sometimes will um
almost make it like you want your front
wheels to come off the ground a little
bit so if you can add an extra 200
pounds in this scenario here
well that's like one of me just standing
on the front of the tractor help keeping
it planted to the ground
while i'm pushing or plowing that snow a
lot of us are dealing with hills
okay there's no way around it you just
have hilly property you still have work
to get done
that's where a setup like these dual
wheels can come in handy or maybe
wheel spacers to get a little bit wider
footprint here
these tractors are not very stable side
to side you could find yourself in some
dangerous situations
you need to find a way to make it safe
to do that work and so whether it's
through the dual wheels the wheel
spacers maybe a combination of one of
those items along with wheel weights
liquid ballast to really lower your
center of gravity it's going to make a
big difference to operating safely and
efficiently on your tractor
so while the form of ballast or
stability could change depending on the
user
the one thing i can tell you is we all
need some version of it
so that's it guys the bare essentials
what every tractor owner needs to know
needs to have that's just my opinion if
you have something else you think
belongs on this list leave a comment
down below
and did you figure out what changed from
the beginning of the video to the end
as always i'd love it if you give me a
thumbs up and if you want to see more
cool tractor videos hit that subscribe
button right down below
and as always read through the
description as well all sorts of helpful
links down there for tractor owners or
head on over to goodworkstractors.com
thanks so much for stopping by and until
next time stay safe we'll see you soon
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you